number one is oil prices right I mean
oil in the wake of the death of King
Abdullah of Saudi Arabia the commodity
rose initially but as since we've lower
Saudi Arabia the biggest producer and
OPEC and largely the biggest factor
right in what's happened here with oil
prices initially there was some
speculation that that the policy might
change here in production levels but it
looks like not and not for the short
term but aside from the succession plan
you really have to look at who's
influences oil prices and its really the
oil minister I'll nighy me and the
question is he's almost 80 years old
he's talked about wanting to retire so
who would take his place some analysts
are telling me will be the CEO of Saudi
Aramco who seems to be on the same page
in terms of the Saudi oil policy but
that's really the position to watch
because the King can quite frankly do
whatever he wants yeah I wanted to
change it and obviously there's a much
larger macro story going on here that's
ultimately going to be the larger
influence of oil prices so we saw a sort
of a whipsaw thing today and then I
think investors are even going to again
go back to focusing on the bigger
picture here you know I heard someone
say to me last week that you know if
you're looking for a world central bank
might say Saudi Arabia is the world
central bank with what they've done how
they have influenced so many central
banks around the world and their own
economies and currencies just given what
we've seen with lower oil prices okay
lower oil prices may have many investors
worried but it's not getting in the way
of the bull market according to
billionaire hedge fund manager Lee
Cooperman who was on with us yesterday
and said he didn't see much a short
euphoria in the markets yet I don't see
any euphoric behavior in the stock
market you know a comment I made the
past quoting John Templeton bull markers
are born and despair they grow the
growing skepticism they mature and
optimism they die in euphoria we don't
have euphoria as evidenced by an
individual investor exposure to equity
assets you know a pension plans are less
than fifty percent equities yeah you
don't have the sense that people are
exuberant